[Musique]
il ya quelques années je finis ma
licence en technique de commerce et
marketing et comme beaucoup de mes
camarades j'ai été jeté sur le marché de
l'emploi le taux de chômage est élevé il
y avait plein de prédicateurs de
l'auto-emploi chacun tenté tant bien que
mal de sortir la tête de l'eau
aujourd'hui il réfléchit je pense que
cela aurait été si le plan socio
économique plus bénéfique d'apprendre à
ct a trouvé que de créer un boulot on
parlait de ceux qui sont partis de zéro
pour devenir euros on ne parle pas de
ceux qui sont tombés du rock ou de
venise 0 on ne parle pas de ceux qui
boivent dans les bas parce qu'ils ont
perdu la confiance de la famille et des
amis
on ne parle pas de ceux qui sont
poursuivis par des huissiers parce
qu'ils ont fait de patiner pour plus
jamais remplacer on ne parle pas de ceux
qui ne peut plus lever la tête dans la
société parce qu'ils ont eu
choubette70 contre le fait qu'on parle
de ceux qui réussissent
ça me motive ça permet de prendre
l'envol mai étudier des cas d'échec
afin de minimiser des risques inutiles
pour un fils d'objectifs est une école
pendant que se jouer le championnat des
jeunes assoiffés de devenir des pdg peut
apporter une solution aux problèmes de
la société
moi à ma formation académique et celle
que j'ai glané sur l'entrepreneuriat çà
et là
j'associe mona mona de slam et de
rigoler de tchatcher de draguer les
filles jusqu'au jour où j'obtiens en
stage professionnel dans une banque de
la place
beaucoup de mes amis me disaient que
j'avais de la chance mais moi j'étais
motivé pas le salaire que les aurais
bancaire avec le code vestimentaire pour
quelqu'un qui était déjà habitué à se
coucher car se rêvait et a comme moi se
conformer aux règles de la banque
s'était vraiment pas de la patate
je me souviens une fois avait été
renvoyé de la banque pouvant porter une
veste mais sans cravate
mais en dépit de tous ces détails que je
trouve air frivole
j'ai même au boulot j'étais chargé de
clientèle et mon rôle était de fidéliser
et de la ji la taille de la clientèle un
moment donné notre banque a décidé
d'élargir sa clientèle au niveau de la
couche estudiantine à mon premier
contact avec les étudiants
j'ai été choqué de voir la façon dont
les étudiants cultive les mentalités à
demeure pauvre
sinon je ne comprenais pas pourquoi les
étudiants me disaient qu'ils sont
pauvres et qu'ils ne voulaient pas créer
gratuitement un compte épargne
j'ai compris très tôt que les étudiants
ont envie de devenir riche mais n'a pas
la mentalité des pagnes aux le fait
d'avoir la mentalité des pagnes appelle
la richesse c'est comme la loi de
l'attraction vous apprêtez votre esprit
à recevoir ce que vous espérez en posant
des actes physique
si vous voulez revenus de votre champ à
bessong aller aux champs avec un stade
qui peut contenir au moins 100 membres
sinon si vous allez avec le sac ne peut
compter ni que 10 vous allez revenu avec
dimanche même si on taille pleuvait des
milliers de manques dans votre champ
l'autre barrière que les étudiants se
créait pour ne pas oser pour ne pas et
pan du risque de ne pas rêver grand est
est la barrière de financement les
étudiantes parlait beaucoup plus de
financements finances nous avons de bons
projets nous avons de belles idées mais
la banque ne vais pas le financer la
banque ne veut pas nous accompagne la
botte ne veut pas en fait si la banque
ne veut pas nous fait ça en ignorant que
quand vous avez la compétence la nature
met à votre disposition le minimum pour
réussir votre projet je me répète quand
vous avez la compétence la nature met à
votre disposition le minimum pour
réussir votre projet c'est pas la joie
qui attend les idées c'est les idées qui
attendent la jambe parce que quand vous
avez l'agent vous n'avez plus le temps
de réfléchir
quand vous avez la compétence la nature
met à votre disposition le minimum pour
ici je vais partager une histoire avec
vous j'y fais ma petite soeur qui a 12
ans à la poche du nouvel an un ami de la
famille lui offrait en guise de cadeau
de noël une lapine l'idée initiale était
de fait de 2,7 lapine le plat de fête un
moment donné mais froid se sont
familiarisés avec cet animal est l'idée
initiale a changé désormais il avait
envie de les lever
notre ami de la famille ayant appris le
sérieux
l'amour que poté mes frais pour cet
animal leur donnant un autre pays
2 0 mais fred avait déjà deux lapins de
quoi réaliser leurs rêves
les parents pour les encourager leur
donner une cage chacun s'investisse et
ils sacrifient le petit déjeuner pour
nourrir ses lapins mais après des
semaines de semaine de travail
cette lapine ne donnait aucun lapinou un
moment donné ils ont appelé un canicule
d'heure qui les a aidés à griffes ans
étaient là l'an ping après quelques
jours on pouvait espérer enfin de
lapinot ce qui fût il y avait de la joie
ça jacasse et shahzad dans c'est pas
tout mais faute de pommiers soins après
quelques jours c'est l'appui nos moeurs
dépité mes frères et ma soeur députés
mais pas découragés ils ont aussi été
forgé le leur rêve aussi les deux lapins
qui restent et ils ont continué à nouri
assez investi mais pape ou pas plus pour
longtemps car après quelques jours un
beau matin il découvrait les deux lapins
morts dans le cache ma petite soeur
fleury sera aussi ont pleuré mais les
lames ne pourront plus ramené les petits
déjeuners sacrifier le temps l'énergie
qu'ils ont gaspillé dans cette aventure
c'est ainsi que de nous deux belles
idées de projets meurent chaque année
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la compétence
parce que ne feraient n'avait pas la
compétence dans un premier temps ils ne
savent pas comment élever la paix comme
a fait pour créer une lapine dans un
second temps ils ne savent pas qu'on m'a
apporté les premiers soins et lapinou et
dans un troisième temps ils ne seront
jamais de quoi est mort ses lapins quand
vous avez la compétence la nature met à
votre disposition le minimum pour ici
l'histoire pourrait être un peu plus
différente si en temps mais frais en
russie
ils devront un jour ou bien il dit un
jour qui sont partis de zéro ou devenir
héros moi je dirais ils sont partis de
la compétence pour devenir ce qu'ils
sont quand vous avez la compétence la
nature met à votre disposition le
minimum pour ici alors ma génération
merci
[Applaudissements]